Rosalind Singleton has died following a
long battle with brain cancer she was 39
years old
all right grab your tissues because
you're going to need them Roslyn's
journey unfolded across her inspiring TV
appearances Ray and I were in the
doctor's office three to four times a
week I feel personally that God gives
battles to certain people Roslyn's
husband Ray confirmed her death on
Instagram opening up about the long and
difficult road ahead quote our wife
earned her wings while peacefully
sleeping right at home where she wanted
to be now we celebrate her Legacy her
impact her story and her spirit
fans have been following the couple
stories since 2020 after Rey shared a
video serenading Rosalind leading up to
a surgery
[Music]
the video went viral and it didn't take
long for Ellen DeGeneres to send the
parent invitation to her daytime talk
show 2013 was my first surgery and first
bowel with brain cancer and was stage
three the first time and the tumor was
the size of an orange I don't even
understand that yeah neither could I in
a heartfelt tribute the comedian said
she's devastated writing quote she was
such a light in the face of really
difficult circumstances I hope her
memory inspires you the way it inspires
me actually the reason I'm here is
because of my wife the following year
Roslyn supported Rey as he auditioned
for America's Got Talent I told him that
I wanted for him to live his dream and
I'm so proud of him being here I'm sorry
I'm so proud of him being here I really
am
and tonight I am very happy to announce
that she is cancer free but later
Roslyn's cancer returned and it was
stage four Roslyn endured multiple
surgeries and several rounds of
radiation and chemotherapy you guys are
inspiration of Love of black love of
support in the comments of Rey's
announcements some of Roslyn's high
profile followers showed their love
Sherry Shepard wrote I am thankful that
you chose to share your life and your
love with us and Dwyane Wade thanked the
couple for quote allowing us all to
celebrate you and become a part of your
lives whatever I needed to do I knew I
was going to do it in one of their final
TV appearances Ray praised his wife's
fighting Spirit some people don't make
it through one brain surgery
she's made it through four
and look at her
[Music]